Hello everybody!
Welcome back to MoreMonkey!
Yes, three monkeys this week.
I can't help it.
I actually have been enjoying Wukong a lot lately.
So like, I know like I usually do it like once a week, but then today's special... this week has been special!
It's been a very enjoyable game series so far and I heard it is very, very long in general.
I thought chapter two was long, but apparently chapter three is like times two longer than chapter two.
So yeah, I'm definitely not going to be finishing chapter three in one stream because I do have to do a convention stuff later tonight.
So I can't be too dead inside.
All right.
So, oh my God, I should have got coffee before the stream.
I was like debating.
I was like, oh my God, do I get coffee?
But I was like, no, no, I'm strong enough.
I am so much stronger than this.
I don't need coffee.
I don't need extra substances to keep me going.
I was wrong.
I'm always wrong.
Instead, I have water.
I have no caffeine in my apartment at the moment.
I only have water.
I have water and iced tea.
And I don't think the iced tea is going to help me here.
Bite size.
Thank you for the acasupa.
Thank you.
It's time for more monkey business.
We're back.
We're back yet again with some more monkey business.
All right.
Life update.
Wait.
Fuck.
I should have wrote this down.
Okay.
What did I want to give you guys for life update?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Never mind.
No life update because I already forgot.
I already forgot what the life update was.
I was like, should I write this down before?
And I was like, no, I'll definitely remember it.
Oh my gosh.
I can't.
I forgot.
I was like, oh man, maybe I should write it.
I was like, no, no, it'll be fine.
I don't need to write it down.
Surely I'll remember what I wanted to talk about.
Surely.
I forgot.
I have no life.
That's the life update.
Oh my gosh.
I forgot.
I'm so mad.
That's the life update.
Oh, my gosh.
What was it?
God dammit.
It was on the tip of my tongue.
I was so excited to tell you about a life update.
But now do I even have a life?
Like do I?
Maybe I'll come back later.
Yeah.
Well, I talked about yesterday's convention.
When, like, majority of the games, because I haven't been touching Apex Legends for a while now, I think the last time I streamed it, whenever that was, was the last time I played Apex.
But then the rules were Wingman and Peacekeeper.
And, you know, I was like, Wingman and Peacekeeper.
I was like, those are two of the guns that I never use.
Like, I was like, oh, man, Wingman and Peacekeeper.
Those were, yeah, I was like, oh, man, especially with 150 ping, too.
I was not, not, you know, I was just like, definitely, this is not gonna be a good time for me.
I'm so fucking washed.
And I gotta use two of the most, two of the guns that I'm definitely not very well known for.
With 150 ping.
Peacekeeper, I actually haven't touched the Peacekeeper in, I think, a while now.
I think, like, more than four plus months now.
Because, like, why use a Peacekeeper when I could use, like, when usually people don't use short-range guns anymore in Apex.
We always use, like, long-range guns.
We use long-range and short mid-range.
So, because it's just more safe versus shotguns.
Shotguns are not safe at all.
So, like, I haven't used Peacekeeper in a very long time.
And I won every match.
I won every one.
I got a little bit toxic.
And just started punching people.
Because I was like, alright, I'm gonna get freebies.
I'm just gonna start punching instead.
And, um, yeah.
And they were like, please have mercy.
And I was like, no mercy.
I know you guys really wanna beat me.
So why should I give you guys mercy?
Uh.
Butchop, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Toki.
I flew all the way to Malaysia to see you yesterday.
I'm watching you absolutely body.
50 plus dragoons was fun.
I'm still not sorry for calling you fu- Oh my god, that was you?!
Alright.
This fucker.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, so what happened was that, um, there was a Q&A session.
And then the MC was like, oh, hey, why don't we get that person with the boob- uh, not sorry, the Doki mouse pad.
And I was like, oh, oh, please don't tell me it's booba.
Like, don't tell me it's a booba mouse pad.
And then, so then he came up and then he was like, oh, don't worry.
You're, you're too flat for booba mouse pad.
So like, I'm going to fucking time you out right now.
Anyway.
Wow.
You show your face.
I fando stab you.
Oh, he is.
Is he?
Yes, he is.
He is wrong.
What do you mean?
Is he wrong though?
Yes, he is wrong.
There is a bump.
Okay.
There is a bump and he is wrong.
Anyway.
Uh, punishment done.
But it was really fun, honestly.
It was a nice ego boost, doing those Apex 1v1s, because I was not gonna lie, I was like, do I even warm up for this?
I was like, oh no, no, warming up isn't gonna help me.
I actually went in with zero warm up, and I was like, oh whatever, like, it'll make them happy when they win against me.
So, yeah, thanks for boosting my ego, Dragoons.
I really appreciate it.
It made me realize that, wow, I am a gamer.
I was like, damn, wow, maybe I am good at video games.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I am the gamer of the year.
Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, I am still washed.
I am still washed, but even when in my washed state, I'm still...
It's just gonna be, like, tomatoes.
If I ever have, like, a booba mouse pad, the booba part is just gonna be two big-ass tomatoes.
Anyway, uh, today we're gonna be continuing Wukong!
I'm super excited to do more monkey.
I think next week I'm definitely gonna, uh, I'm just gonna say, like, my brain is still waking up.
I even took, like, a nap, too.
I took, like, a, uh, a 12 p.m.
nap because, uh, Dokian Burdoj, aka Dad, wakes me, wakes me up at, like, oh my god, okay.
He's such a little shit right now.
Um, uh, basically, um, like, he...
He... okay, I'm definitely... I don't know.
I'm definitely gonna, like, feed him a little bit less because today, this morning, he pooped three times.
And I was like, what's... what's going on with your body?
I was like, oh my god, what did I... am I... did I feed you too much?
I was like, no way, I feed you the same... I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
I pooped three times.
So I was like, alright, it's diet time.
It's... it's...
And the worst part is that the first...
The first two times, it wasn't even outside... like, it wasn't even, like, on the grass.
It was like, um...
It was like... like, we were just walking on the sidewalk to the grass.
And, like, we literally took three steps.
We took three steps outside the... the lobby door.
And then he, like, he was like, it's crouching time.
I was like, why are you crouching?
Why... why are you... why are you...
I was like... I was like, wait.
Why are you... why are you crouching?
You don't do that!
You don't do...
I was like, what?
What do you mean it's crouching time?
He's got him on his new territory.
He accidentally... he accidentally pressed C on accident.
Yeah, just like the... just like the crow game.
He got a little too excited.
He got a little bit too excited there.
But, yes, he's definitely... I'm gonna be feeding him a little bit... not, like, a lot less.
Just a little bit less.
Because that concerned me.
I was like, three is a little bit too much.
Like, two... two, okay.
Maybe two... he... he just... his stomach is being a little extra quirky.
But three times, I was like, okay.
And they're not, like, you know, it's not, like, like...
Like, oh, maybe there's something...
Maybe he's sick.
I know he's not sick.
And I was like, that's not the right life update, by the way.
But I was just like, yeah, I'm just... you're gonna be eating a little bit less now.
He's gonna start complaini-
Oh my god.
But no, that wasn't the life... I wish I remember what my life update was.
I don't remember!
Oh, I hate it!
Do you... I...
I hate it when...
There's something you want to talk about and it's just there.
You can sort of remember it, but not really.
And it's like so annoying.
Ah!
Okay, okay.
Sorry, I just need to yell out my frustrations right there.
I just need to yell out my frustrations.
Hydration time.
Oh yeah, it's next week.
I will be taking a little bit of like...
I know I've been taking a lot of like breaks recently.
I really hate it, not gonna lie.
Because I feel like I'm losing momentum whenever I do do it.
But like a lot of my breaks haven't really been breaks, breaks, breaks.
And like the move has been... oh my god.
The move has been like a lot.
I know.
I've stopped unpacking since I set up my work PC.
I've like stopped unpacking.
So I feel like I really do need to actually start unpacking stuff.
And like fully reset myself.
So like next week it might not be like an actual break, break.
But like there's definitely gonna be like a little bit less...
Like it's not gonna be the same amount of streams, you know?
Yeah.
So I might be doing like two to three streams and then the rest would just be like hibernation day.
So yeah, I just want to give you guys a little warning up ahead about that.
I wish I remember what my life update was.
What the fuck did I want to...
I just out!
I'll never remember!
There's like nothing...
There's not that much exciting stuff going on with my life at the moment.
So I'm like, how do I forget?
How the fuck do I forget?
There's nothing exciting going on.
I'm literally just existing right now.
Like I'm chronically online.
But there was like something...
Oh yes, deadlock!
That's it!
Oh my god.
Thank you so much.
I wanted to talk about deadlock.
Sorry, I forgot.
The majority of my life updates relies on being online as well.
So...
Oh my god.
Alright, deadlock!
I can finally talk about deadlock.
I've been in the...
The reason why I can't say anything about it was because I've been in the fucking beta...
What was it?
The alpha program since March slash April.
So like, I hate it.
I literally played less than five times.
I've been in it since like...
March, April.
And like, I played it less than five times.
Because it can...
I feel like...
Okay, the reason why I don't like it is...
No, it's not that it's bad.
It's that it's League of Legends.
It's literally...
I got tricked into playing League.
Like...
So if you like League, then you'll like deadlock.
But like, I got...
I don't like MOBAs.
So...
Yeah, it's basically a MOBA game.
But it's like a first person.
And like, the thing is...
Back in the early...
Because I was invited very early on.
I was invited super early on.
So not a lot of like... Because I know like now there's a lot of like actual like casual player base now.
But like, when I was invited to play it, it was mostly like content creators and like League players.
So like, I was fucking playing against Dyrus and Surefour.
Like, every time I like got on.
So I had not the best of times playing the game.
Because I was always playing against League players.
And then...
The thing is...
You can't stop playing.
It's literally a 30 to 40 minute game.
Actual League.
Actual fucking League.
I don't understand that reference.
Basically the people I was playing against were actual League players.
Who can aim.
So like...
So...
Yeah, so like you're stuck in the game for like 30 to 40 plus minutes.
And you can't forfeit.
There's no forfeit.
I don't know if they added forfeit now.
But like...
There's no forfeit.
Like the games are on average for like 40 plus minutes.
Just like actual... Just like regular League.
And... I don't know.
Maybe they added it now.
But like...
I did not have a good time.
As somebody that doesn't like League...
I did not have like a very good time.
But if you...
If you like League...
You can just CC.
Yes!
But when I was playing it, it was like mostly content creators and like high elo League of Legends players.
So like I couldn't just DC because they'll know who I am.
They're like...
They're...
They're people in the community.
So I don't know who I am.
So I couldn't just...
I couldn't just leave.
...
And...
And so...
Um...
So yes!
If you like League... That's what I'm saying.
Remember when I told you guys like I made that joke about like Who is this game?
Like I don't remember what game it was.
But it was another game that's similar to Deadlock.
We saw a trailer for it during during Gamescom.
And I was like who is this for?
I was like, there's not a lot of overlap because a lot of people that play FPS games don't really like to play League.
And a lot of people that play League don't really like to play FPS games.
So it's like such a small overlap of like...
It's such a small overlap of like people.
Like, I'm one of those.
I'm one of those FPS players that don't like MOBAs.
Because like, it hurts my brain.
I was like, it hurts my...
No, it's not Concord.
Concord is like the... it's like...
It looks like a fucking boring ass hero shooter.
It was just...
Yes, but Pokemon.
Pokemon Unite is different.
It's like Baby League.
And I'm a baby.
I'm...
It's like...
It's basically baby...
It's League for babies.
And like League for babies, I like...
It's a baby game.
And like at least I get to beat up children.
And it's so easy to learn.
But like, I don't know.
I think like if you like League...
If you like FPS games, you won't like Deadlock.
But if you like...
Oh, sorry.
If you like shooters in general...
I don't know if you'll like Deadlock.
But if you like League, you'll really like Deadlock.
Because I...
I couldn't...
I couldn't like it.
I...
Because like, I know some people are like, Oh, are you going to stream Deadlock?
I'm just like, I already tried.
I already tried to like it during Alpha.
During the...
I don't know, the...
Whatever the test...
It wasn't even called Deadlock when I got in.
I don't even remember what the old name was.
It was...
I don't even remember what it was called.
It was like...
There was...
It had a different name other than Deadlock.
But like, if you like League, you'll like Deadlock.
But like, I don't like League.
And I don't like MOBAs.
So like, I couldn't like Deadlock.
I was just like, it's...
I was like, oh my god, I can't.
I don't know.
.
I was just...
Oh man, I couldn't.
I couldn't.
I just couldn't.
I tried my best to try to like it.
But I was just like, I can't force myself.
I can't force myself to like this game.
I...
To be fair, people are just surprised that Valve made video games again.
Because they don't have to.
They literally can just live off Steam money.
So like, everybody was just surprised.
That, you know, Valve actually made a game.
Because they literally did not have to do that.
Like, they could just live off making money off of Steam for the rest of their life.
.
So that's like, good for them.
You know?
Good for them.
They tried something.
I honestly, I don't know.
I don't know if the game is going to actually...
I don't know.
The game is obviously not made for me.
Like, you know, because I have different tastes and stuff.
Like, we're not...
I'm not...
Like, you know, people are not supposed to like everything.
If you like everything.
Like, every single game you've ever played.
Or like, not every single game that ever came out.
Then like...
Good for you, I guess.
Then...
Good for you.
You're a happier person than the rest of us.
At that point, you've like achieved true happiness.
If you like everything.
But like, I know what my tastes and preferences are when it comes to video games.
And that...
Definitely not that.
Deadlock was definitely not it for me.
Anyway.
Anyway, it's time for Monkey.
That was the life update I wanted to give you guys.
That was it.
Honestly.
Alright, continue the journey!
We're back to being a monkey!
Yeah, bro achieved true enlightenment.
Alright, here we go.
I wonder if we'll meet the rest of Wukong's old gang.
Because we didn't meet like any of the...
I mean, we met like...
Okay, no, that's not true.
I was thinking like, have we met any of Wukong's like old buddies yet?
I feel like we haven't.
We've only seen them in like cutscenes.
And like in like...
In like...
Like we met the priest.
Like in...
Not like meet me, but like we saw him in a cinematic.
Hmm.
Magic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just like to suffer, I guess.
Alright.
Where do we go?
Oh my gosh, I don't even know where I came from.
I mean, this map is...
Will make me as equally lost.
Oh, what's this?
Everybody's rocks.
What?
I hope the graphics a lot better though, too.
Oh my God, it's stuttering.
Maybe it's too good.
Okay, no, not anymore.
I was gonna say, do you have to lower the graphics?
Why did that stutter there?
Oh, hey, snow monkey.
Hey.
Monkey?
Say monkey?
Oh.
Wait.
Wait, what?
Wait, what did...
What did monkey not...
Oh!
Monkey, I thought we were friends.
Monkey, why monkey not friends?
I thought we were...
Say monkey.
Okay, new lesser yoga.
Wisdom...
Okay, it's a frozen corpse.
Okay.
Let's say that this...
Why aren't we friends?
You're a monkey.
I'm monkey.
All the gods hate us.
Like, we should be good friends after that.
Yeah, apes together.
Not all monkeys are friends.
But the whole world hates us.
Why can't we be friends?
Oh, is everything stuttering?
Oh my god, my life right now.
Let's see why.
Oh my god!
Okay, this is a little bit of a concern.
I don't know how, but we've managed to hit 98% memory.
I... Ow!
Do I have a memory leak?!
Do I... How did I hit a mem... Oh my god.
Wait, did I restart my PC before?
Okay, guys.
That is an issue.
That is an actual issue.
How the fuck did I hit 98%?!
Holy shit!
Holy fuck, okay.
Alright, we got it.
I gotta close some... Let me close some... Maybe if I close some tabs?
Question mark!
I don't even have that many tabs open!
How is that possible?!
Oh, hey.
Oh yeah, I was looking up Connect the Crow.
So, do you guys remember when I was talking about...
When I was talking about that crow that was, like, terrorizing people?
So, like, it was the same... And the crow with the knife?
It was the same crow.
It was literally the same crow.
The crow with the knife?
So, apparently...
Apparently, this crow... His name was Connect the Crow.
And he used to own... He had, like... He owned the streets, basically.
So, like, mail... The post office...
Canada Post had to suspend mail deliveries for a specific street.
Because, like, the crow was attacking mailmen.
So, they're like, sorry, we can't deliver to your street anymore because there's a crow that's terrorizing everybody.
I thought that was just...
Oh, fuck.
Fucking funny.
I was like, it was one crow.
It was one crow.
And, like, they're like...
They actually suspended mail delivery for that street.
For three different streets.
I was like, that's so fucked.
Imagine living at that street.
And you're just like, we can't deliver your mail because this crow is trying to take our mailmen's money.
It was...
He was also the same crow with the knife.
By the way.
It was literally the same crow.
I was...
I was very surprised to find out it was the same fucking crow.
Alright, let's see.
I did close some tabs.
Is it better now?
Are you...
Are you feeling a little...
Shh, PC.
Are you feeling better, PC?
Softly caresses the PC.
Are you...
Are you doing okay?
Okay.
Let's see if this helps it.
I deleted a few tabs.
Alright.
I deleted the...
I deleted the connector crow tab because I was reading up on it.
Alright.
Alright, that feels a lot better.
Now that I'm not at, like, you know...
A hundred.
Oh!
Fake.
Oh shit!
Wait, why is he so strong?
Why am I so weak?
Alright.
Maybe we gotta upgrade our staff.
I heard that there's a dragon we have to beat up to get staff updates.
Alright, let's make sure there's nobody here.
Oh fuck, I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew it.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
You too?
You're supposed to be frozen!
If you move, you're not actually frozen!
What's that word called when, like, it's not what...
It's advertised.
False advertisement!
This is false advertisement right now.
Question.
Why your channel name is Doki Bird?
I'm curious.
Thank you for the super chat, Daniel.
Thank you.
Because I'm a bird.
That goes Doki Doki.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh no!
Wait!
I have a better answer.
Scratch what I just said.
Because I'm a bird that makes you go Doki Doki.
Wink.
Alright.
Oh, I never even offered the incense.
Oh, wait.
I did.
Alright.
Nice.
That's right.
So smooth.
So fucking smooth.
Alright.
60.
This is the weapon I have, right?
Yeah.
That's the weapon I'm using.
This one's 70.
Okay.
So...
Alright.
We gotta go kill the dragon to get this one.
Uh...
Where is it?
Where's the secret?
So smooth.
Alright.
Where's the secret for...
Uh...
For that dragon?
It has to be...
It's the mountains, right?
Yeah.
But where?
God dammit!
Oh!
Damn!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Black wind.
And then where?
Cave.
Interior.
Outside.
Peak.
Waterfall?
Where the fuck is the waterfall?
There's no waterfall here.
Outside?
Outside the cave?
Is this?
Remember the snake guy?
No.
He was pretty forgettable, though.
Okay.
It's with the baby?
Wait.
This baby?
Outside of the forest?
Oh my god.
Where did I kill the baby?
I...
I don't remember.
I don't remember!
I don't even...
Guys.
I don't rem...
It's...
It's been 20 years since I've killed that baby.
It's been...
20 years.
I...
What is it called?
Is it the forest hills?
Is it outside?
Oh!
It's outside!
It's the baby!
I see him!
It's okay.
I found him.
I saw the baby.
It's okay, guys.
I found him.
It's over for him.
The baby.
Well, you never get to grow up to be an adult.
It's a little...
God.
A little dark there.
Whoa.
Mistakes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I bought this game because of you.
Here's your commission, I guess.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
I saw my...
Got my Aspie from that baby.
And you're like, I don't care.
I got my Aspie too.
All right.
How strong am I now to these guys?
Boom!
What?
It takes me two hits.
My staff is plus 60.
How does it take two hits?
All right.
Where is it?
To the left, right?
Someone mentioned it's to the left.
Oh!
That waterfall!
Okay.
I see it.
Oh.
It's the pole guy!
All right.
Alright, nice.
Goodbye.
I have to kill the crow again!
Oh wait, I killed him.
Alright, examine.
Fuck water!
No more waterfalls in this town.
Oh, is he talking about the boss I'm going to fight?
Alright, first boss today.
I'm so dead.
I don't think...
I don't think I'm ready to fight him.
But let's do it.
I'm going to make sure I have everything I need.
Okay, I have big baby.
I have my staff.
I have...
Do I have the items I want for this?
Okay, reduce his cooldown.
Okay.
I just want to be sure.
I want to be sure I have everything I need.
Alright, and these are all the items I'm not using.
These are everything I'm not using.
Okay.
Alright, gotta make sure.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, time to beat up another dragon.
You know, I'm really surprised.
Like, how...
What's the word?
Like...
There's not a lot of loading screens, you know?
For this game.
And like...
It's usually like one loading screen per chapter.
There's so much stuff going on with one area.
That's so nice.
Alright.
It's going to be another dragon, right?
Whoa!
Oh!
Red dragon!
That's so long.
You're not red, you're blue.
You're mostly blue.
That's like...
a lie.
How are you red?
Oh, I forgot how to use power-ups.
No!
I didn't say it.
I forgot.
I...
I said it.
Wait, he killed all the monkeys?
What the fuck was the point?
I already used up all of it.
Oh no, you're not dead.
Okay, thank god.
Okay, I assume I have to hit this.
Okay, me and my one monkey that's not dead.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
One monkey survived somehow.
Holy fuck.
That's actually bullshit.
Oh my god.
I can't believe all the monkeys died except for that one monkey.
What?
That's not fair.
All my monkeys died except for that one monkey.
That is actually not fair.
That is...
Like, what's the point?
Oh shit!
Okay.
What's the point of using that monkey power?
Oh, please!
Please.
I'm just a little monkey.
Alright.
Come on.
Get over here.
Come on!
Fuck!
Did I hit him?
Oh, I did.
Okay.
Thank god I did.
Oh my god.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh.
When do you use that?
Alright.
You know what?
I like your brother more.
At least he had some sick ass jams.
His music was better.
Yeah, that's right.
I said it.
He had better taste in music than you.
That's right.
I fucking said it.
Your music tastes as good as your brother.
That's fucking right.
Bam!
That's why you're easier to kill.
Haha.
I'm joking.
That's fucked.
You can't just roast his music choices.
First try.
Dist and destroy.
Okay.
My fucking little monkeys got so fucked up there.
Alright.
Oh, long pearl.
What else did I get?
I got the thunder tail.
What else?
I got the censor, so now I can never curse again.
Alright.
How do I get out of this area?
Where's the exit?
Oh my god.
I wasn't supposed to beat him in first try.
And I don't know where the exit is.
How do I leave?
Is it up here?
Is it?
Away from the tree.
Okay.
It's up here.
I don't know.
I didn't die, so I don't know where to go.
Is this it?
Oh, there it is.
The tiny hole.
Alright.
Okay.
I think I'm good to go.
I mean, the way I came.
I went through the hole and I got into a cutscene.
And then they transported me into the fight.
Hahaha.
That's true.
The true boss is navigation.
This is why... This is what I don't like about Souls games.
But like, that's on me though.
It's not because the game's bad.
It's because I'm directionally challenged.
Like, it's not the game's fault.
I'm just really bad at read...
Like, really bad at maps.
Or like, not maps, but navigation.
I'm so directionally challenged.
Okay.
No maps.
Only west.
Like, right now, I'm like, where the fuck did I...
Where... Where is the... Where is the... Where's the... The shrine?
And you guys are gonna be like, Oh my god, Doki.
Just use the... No!
I will not use the fucking...
Use that thing to bring me back.
I can do this myself.
I don't need no help.
Hahaha.
I don't need extra help.
I don't need to teleport.
I'm a strong independent bird.
What can I make now?
The back scratcher?
What?
Wait!
Is it one time use?
Is this like... Is this a consumable?
It says...
It doesn't say hug.
Guys, my back's scratchy.
I love... I used to love these.
It's an equipment?
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, I don't need that then.
I craft.
Can I craft that?
The strong stuff now?
I can.
I just... Okay, maybe there's gold.
Do I have gold?
Uh... Stores...
It's an accessory.
Oh, yes I do.
Nice.
I knew grave robbing was not a mistake.
Hahaha.
Alright, craft weapons.
Can I craft it now?
No!
It's still... Oh wait, that's...
I still don't have enough will.
But what if...
What if I... But... Oh no.
They won't let me sell anything.
Alright, it's time to farm.
How much do I need to farm again?
Alright, I'm gonna beat up some of the lesser wolves here.
Get over here.
I need 500 will.
It's your lucky day.
Just like the apex goons.
Okay, plus 81.
Okay!
Uh...
Alright.
Where are all these...
Where are all these wolves?
They won the lottery!
But where are they?
I was gonna say, did all of them run away because they know?
Hahaha!
They're like, oh no.
Oh no, she's coming.
Alright, plus 25.
You don't give that much though.
You don't really give that much.
How about you?
How much do you give?
Plus 32.
Alright, plus 29.
Oh wait, I'm looking at experience.
Okay, plus 28.
Okay.
God, I need to find a place that has like...
What's the best place to farm will?
Do these give will?
No.
They see my bloodlust.
I need to find like a place to farm will.
I need to farm.
I need to farm some guise.
Maybe in chapter 3.
Maybe I could.
Yeah, you're right.
Alright.
Oh, 28.
Oh, they gave me gold!
God!
I love it when they kindly gave me gold and not because I killed them.
Alright, nice.
More will.
Okay, there should be...
How much more do I need now?
Must not be that much, right?
Oh, 300!
Or less than 300.
Alright, travel, new west.
Alright.
The frost guise might give me more.
204.
Yeah.
I might as well go to the...
I need to be in the snow area anyway.
So like, I might as well.
Alright.
I don't know why that's a TikTok meme.
I saw it or like YouTube shorts meme.
I don't know if you guys saw it but it was like a bunch of family members being like Give me your money.
And then they're all like, yay, like, give me your money.
I don't understand.
Am I just getting old?
It's like a new...
It's like a new fucking Gen Alpha YouTube's shorts slash TikTok meme.
And what's my algorithm?
It's called being a fucking normie.
That's somehow...
Somehow like...
Somehow always online.
It's a mistake.
My algorithm, it's a fucking mistake.
That's what...
To be fair, like, Gen Alpha memes are like super surreal now.
Like, humor has evolved into...
I feel like the older we get, the more surreal the humor has become.
Like, I know back then, our fucking humor was like, eee, and then it was like Markiplier's face.
But like, I don't know how we managed to get even more surreal than that.
Like...
You can't be like, oh, but like, back in my day, our humor was so...
Our humor was so much better.
We literally thought E was the funniest shit ever.
Like, every...
Every gen has its like, fucked up face.
Okay?
I still need...
Oh, prerequisites required?
Oh, I have to craft...
No!
I need to craft prerequisites!
We gotta craft this then.
So we can unlock that.
And then now I...
God damn it!
I didn't craft it.
I forgot there's prerequisites.
Our humor was superior.
We all had...
We all had our phases.
Back to chapter 3.
Back to Suffer, we go.
From 200 to 2700.
Let's go.
I like how you can sorta tell where the which one's the enemy.
Because you literally just have to lock in.
Boop!
Alright.
Alright, nice.
Oh wait, what?
Oh yeah, they had to move a little bit before too.
Hello!
Just lock it in.
Yeah, it's that easy.
Oh, what the fuck!
Okay, I keep forgetting they move after.
After they die.
Oh!
Did somebody cry?
Why are you crying?
You're not allowed to cry.
Oh, the chief?
Why is that we're friends?
What happened to apes together in Strang?
Was that all a lie?
Planet of the Apes lied to me!
I can't believe it!
But what happened to Planet of the Apes?
Big attack.
Oh shit.
Oh, Firestrike gets ice!
That's what Pokemon taught me!
There we go.
Oh shit.
Why can't I have a sword?
Like, I know like...
Yeah, like, Shroomhong uses a staff, but like...
Why can't we just give him a gun?
Imagine Shroomhong with a gun.
That's some...
Fucking Zhaoxing CA.
Hey, hey, hey.
Save it, man.
Oh, why are you laughing at me?
I defeated you!
Alright.
All I'm saying is that...
I feel like if we give him a gun, it would elevate his character.
It would...
Yeah, like, I know!
I know!
Wukong is bulletproof, but like...
Not the other guys!
The other guys aren't bulletproof!
Miracle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Journey to the west.
I mean, we're heading west anyway!
Like...
Gun Wukong.
Journey to the wild, wild west.
Oh, hello bat.
I mean, you're a willpower bat.
Oh shit.
You can't just stab me with your pitchfork.
What's this?
What about...
What about if the gun was attached to the staff?
And every time he does a thrust, the gun will just go pew pew.
I just think it's very true to his character.
If he just suddenly pulls out a gun.
Like, it won't hurt the gods, but like...
What if it's a magic gun?
Technically the staff...
Like, a normal staff doesn't do jack shit.
A normal staff doesn't jack shit to gods, but my staff is a magic staff.
So like...
So like, we just enchant it with the power of the gods.
You know?
We enchant the gun with the power of the gods.
And then the bullet can kill... can kill any guy at that point.
I'm just talking... I'm just saying real sense here.
Alright, let's see.
Cannot awaken.
Focus for each successful light attack.
Increases the damage dealt.
I feel like I'm gonna get... I'm gonna get the health thing.
The elemental bullet!
Yes!
Imagine having elemental bullets!
Imagine!
If you're...
If you can have elemental bullets!
That shit would be...
That shit would be so strong!
Just think about it!
It would be so strong!
You challenge... will increase the charging speed of all stances.
Heavy attack that causes additional damage to the enemy.
Based on... Ooh!
Wait, that's good.
Alright.
Maybe modify a statuette's stun at a rate of 2,000 pokes per minute.
That would be more sensible for it.
Yeah, but bullet's stronger!
If it had the power of the gods, it would be stronger!
Like, and no fall-off damage too!
That makes it even better.
There would be no fall-off damage.
What the fuck are you?
Oh my god!
What are you?
What the fuck?!
Okay.
Dude, fuck this.
You know I'm gonna cast a...
Oh, I can't cast a baby.
I can't even cast a baby.
What is that?
That shit guy was so strong.
It's a patroller.
With a hideous face and a... Damn!
Okay.
I didn't think he was that ugly, but okay.
Like, drawing him ugly doesn't make him actually ugly.
That's so fucked!
I thought he wasn't that ugly!
But then he's like, with a hideous face and a crooked blade and suede.
I thought he looked like a normal guy.
The journal has some beef with him.
Yeah!
It's not... And like, he purposely drew him so ugly too.
To like, accentuate his point.
Poke!
Alright.
Get him out of here.
Oh, nice.
He doesn't do the little swingy thing too after.
Alright.
This one's also... Oh!
I don't have baby to help me though.
So this might be a little scary.
Oh, wait.
What?
Why am I doing my heavy attack?
This is not fair!
He has so many helpers!
What?!
It's the ugly guy!
Oh, shit.
That's...
That's not good.
Hey, if you're gonna break...
Okay.
I accidentally activated all of them.
That's okay.
That's fine.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
We are stuck.
Okay.
It's fine.
Alright.
Back we go.
Okay.
Nope.
Back we go.
Please.
I'm stuck.
Alright.
Okay.
Do I have enough magic?
I do.
Okay.
Nice.
Poke.
Oh.
Not poke.
Okay.
Come on.
Nice.
Alright.
And...
Big poke!
That's fucking right.
Give me your essence I'll never use because I have big baby!
Profile picture versus IRL.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Give the monkey a gun!
That should be the next DLC.
Give Xiumhong a gun.
I want a modern rendition of Journey to the West.
But like in-game.
Not movies though.
If the movie was made by Zhao Xingqi, then I think it would be pretty funny.
I would...
I feel like if we get a modern Journey to the West movie from Zhao Xingqi then like I think it'd be really funny.
Alright.
Journey to the West side.
I miss peak movies.
But what's his English name again?
I think his Chinese name.
But I always forget what his English name is.
But like I don't think he's had like a good film in a long time.
Stephen Chow.
Yeah.
I feel like... I don't know.
I feel like the last good movie for me... I watched his The Mermaid movie he did.
I didn't like it that much.
But to be fair he... I don't think he...
Did he acted in it?
No I don't think so.
I'm trying to like remember when was the last Stephen Chow... like his most recent Stephen Chow movie that he made that I liked.
And I think like the last one was like... was it the Alien one?
The CJ7?
Oh that shit was sad too.
It was funny and sad.
Kung Fu Hustle one was the best.
I think the amount of times I've watched Kung Fu Hustle.
And um...
The Shaolin Soccer.
Oh.
Let's see...
This way...
For those who don't know who Stephen Chow is...
Um... He is like...
One of the best...
Back then one of the best Hong Kong comedy actors and directors back in the day.
I mean he's still really well known.
But like...
His movies are not as good as it was before.
I will admit.
Yeah he's like legendary.
Yeah I saw the Mermaid one in theaters.
And I was so confused.
Alright.
Oh this cave is not there?
There's so many invisible walls.
I think my favorite Stephen Chow movies are his Journey to the West ones.
And um...
I feel like if anybody can make a really good modern comedy Journey to the West, it would be Stephen Chow.
But like I don't know if he'll...
Unless he gets a lot... Like I feel like he doesn't do much cause like...
Cause he's like at the retirement age.
Where... Also like...
Okay there was this whole thing.
I don't know if it's true.
But...
He used to do... Okay so he was like basically...
It might be like a bit insulting to say.
But he was very like Adam Sandler.
Where he would always cast the same people in the role.
Like he would always cast all his friends.
In...
In movies.
So like...
Uh... So like...
In every movie, it would be the same people.
Because it was like Adam Sandler where all his friends would be in the same...
In the same movie.
Like...
Would always be in the movie.
And he would do that too.
But like...
There was this one actor that I really liked.
What was this?
I read my fortune.
That's fucked.
When do I die?
Oh my god.
It's him.
I'm a bat.
This is like the same thing.
Oh that gives me too much power.
Where am I flying?
Where am I flying to?
Why can't I be a bird?
But yeah, what I was saying.
There was this one actor I really liked in his...
In Steven Child's movies.
Because they worked...
Their chemistry was really, really good.
And then at one point, he stopped appearing in his movies.
Because apparently back then, the rumors was that they had an argument or something.
Like they got into a really big fight.
So he stopped appearing in his movies.
And they were so good together too.
Was it Uncle Tat?
I think so.
I forgot his name.
Yeah, they had a huge falling out.
And then they they were like the...
They had really, really good movie chemistry together.
Really?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna steal stuff.
I got permission from the human chicken thing.
That's enough permission for me.
If a human chicken thing says I can steal it.
Then like, it's not morally wrong.
He seems like a very trustworthy guy.
Alright, let's see.
Do I have anything to sell?
Oh, I can sell all this.
Okay, nice.
I don't have enough money to make new outfits though.
I'm like so...
I'm so fucking poor right now.
That's why I'm stealing stuff.
Alright.
Landmarks are snow, snow, and snow.
I wonder which way do I go.
It's a lot of snow.
Alright.
I also can tell that these guys are not alive because they don't have a...
It's like, alright, if I didn't lock in, it's like, which one is the guy that's gonna try and kill me?
The one over there who's just trying to dance?
That guy over there that's clearly not holding any weapons.
Or this guy with a giant ass fucking...
sword in front of me.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
I was gonna poke you, but I stopped holding.
Right click.
Alright.
Same wolf here.
Also, they're all in the same pose.
I just realized that.
I just realized.
They're all in the same pose.
There's also that too.
Alright, let's get rid of him.
I need that item.
I'm gonna steal the chicken...
That chicken man said it's okay.
He gave me permission to steal.
Alright.
Open up!
Uh, Kara!
Thank you for your very first Super Chat!
Thank you!
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Thank god!
Cutscene buff!
Invincible frames!
Thank god.
Wait, was that supposed to be an ambush?
It's not really an ambush when the chests, like, make sure I don't die when I'm picking stuff up.
Oh my god!
It's time to meditate!
It's time to meditate, guys.
Why can't they give Wukong a gun?
That's all I ask.
That's it.
I've been watching to you live for five minutes.
I noticed you have an adorable voice.
Thank you!
Thank you for the very first Super Chat!
I hope you enjoy being a dragon for the rest of your life.
For his side special, he holds a gun.
Oh my god!
What if we have, like, give him a fucking shotgun?
Give Wukong a shotgun!
Don't be cowards!
If I saw my staff, it should be able to become a shotgun.
Can't be like, that's not accurate.
I'm literally a fucking magic monkey!
Nothing is already accurate!
Oh!
It still remembers my smell?
Sorry, I haven't taken a bath.
I'm roleplaying, by the way.
As the monkey, it's been a while since I took a bath.
I almost can't fit in.
Is that a money bag?
Are you an evil baby?
Come out and help me try on his clothes.
Oh my god, another dragon?
Is it enough?
I have a lot of money!
How many dragons do I have to kill today?
I'm gonna make sure they're all extinct.
He didn't seem so evil.
He seems like a happy Buddha.
This fight was annoying.
Oh my god, he summoned Blue Eyes White Dragon.
I didn't even get the rest!
Oh god, I don't know the pattern.
Okay, big baby.
Please don't miss.
That's all I ask.
Oh yeah, that's right.
Smack that!
Oh!
Okay, he smacked me.
How do I even hit that?
Okay.
Fire vs.
Ice!
I missed!
Fire vs.
Ice!
It's fine.
Oh, it's so fine.
It's so fine.
Does this hurt?
No.
It's just a sail.
Boom!
That's fucking right.
Get down!
Boom!
Who said this fight was annoying?
This fight is so fucking easy!
Because I'm a gamer!
Oh shit.
I lied.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean that.
I think you're a very respectable dragon.
Oh my god, what is he trying to do?
Oh!
Where am I?
Oh no!
Oh god!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
He'll get down, right?
He'll have to get down, right?
I can't see!
No!
Okay, I have to...
I have to unlock.
Alright.
Okay.
I don't like how I have to heal a lot there.
Oh, come on!
Get down!
Oh shit!
Not right now!
But not right now though!
I didn't...
I didn't mean that!
That was a lie!
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
How does that not hit?
This is bullshit!
What part of the body can I fucking hit?
Oh, the head.
Okay, that makes more sense actually.
Oh no!
Wukong, get up!
Wukong!
Get up!
It's just ice!
Oh shit!
Oh...
Oh no, he stunned me too.
Okay, this guy is hard.
Never mind, you're right.
This guy is very...
What?
How do you live that?
Okay, that was bullshit.
That's actually bullshit.
Like, I...
I don't know how to hit him!
Please!
Let me speed dress!
Oh no!
How do I fucking kill him?
There's so much of him!
But it's like...
There's so...
There's so much of him, but like...
Where do I look at?
If I had a gun, I could have just shot him down.
That's all I'm saying.
Guys, if I had...
If I had...
If I could have...
I could have shot him down!
I hate it!
That's literally all I needed!
The gun DLC!
I'll even take a bow at this point!
A bow is basically a prehistoric gun!
It's the same thing!
It's a prehistoric gun!
Alright, we have...
Alright, we got the... we got the... we got the stick.
We got a taller stick now.
Dodge like a cicada and sting like a monkey.
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright...
No, Dottie, no!
Oh no, I'm a little worried.
Dottie's super chat is making me worried right now.
Get closer!
Why are you running away?
Oh my...
Okay, fuck you.
Actually, fuck you.
This shit just killed me.
There's no point.
Restart.
We're restarting.
We're restarting this fight.
Alright.
You learned all the pretty crabs.
We're gonna take in this right now.
Alright, here we go.
I'm coming back.
Alright, this time... this time I'm serious.
This time...
This time I'm actually serious.
I'm serious now.
I'm not fucking around this time.
Alright.
Get down!
For real!
This time.
Alright.
I'm not fucking around now.
We're good.
We're just gonna take a while to travel there, but it'll be worth it.
Because I could be Big Baby.
That's all I want.
I just wanna do...
Big Baby!
Oh shit!
Okay, that's fine.
I have...
Enough HP for this.
Okay, I'm just gonna use the light attack.
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
Alright.
Okay, we gotta be patient.
Now...
Oh no, fuck!
Okay, that was not what I wanted to do.
Now we gotta be patient.
Okay.
Missed the grab.
I think that's his head.
Okay, that is.
Alright.
That's fucking right.
Down from here.
That's right.
The sky is not for you, dragon!
The sky is owned by me!
And the land too!
Oh...
I own the land and the sky!
That's right!
I own everything!
Cause I'm fucking...
Oh!
I'm sorry!
You could have the sky.
I was just joking.
You could...
You could have the sky.
I'm sorry.
I'll...
I'll just take the ground.
The ground's not so bad.
The ground is not as bad as I thought.
The sky denied.
Alright.
Does it need a backup?
Is that a backup?
It'll come down for me, right?
Alright, nice.
Alright, maybe he'll...
Ah, no.
I fucked it up.
That's fucking right!
JK!
Okay, I don't fuck up.
It was fake.
I gave you a false sense of security there.
That's fucking right.
Now I'm gonna get high.
All right, never mind.
Okay, nice.
Nice smack you in the head.
It's fucking right.
Oh, what?
That's not fair!
That's right, I'll smack you in the tail too.
No part of your body is safe from the smacks.
Oh, god.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, please.
Please!
How do you have so much square feet but get none at all?
It's so absolutely bullshit.
There's like so much of this body, but yet I can't paint anything.
Will you ever get down?
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
That's really all I asked.
All right, ask and you shall receive.
Smack!
Big pot, small... like, that should not be legal.
That should not be legal.
Oh, we did it.
We fucking did it.
Wait, what's going on?
What?
,
You have wings?
Wait, you're not the same monkey!
No wonder you didn't want to be friends!
He's not a natural monkey!
Fake monkey!
How the fuck did I get here?
Wait, I got trapped?
But I can't go to jail!
Who's gonna pay my bill?
...
I can't go to jail!
Who's gonna pay my bill?
Please, I'm too poor for bill!
Oh, okay, never mind.
No cage can hold this monkey!
All right, easiest prison break of my life, I guess.
Who's this?
,
?
...
Just kick the door.
No monkey cage, only monkey.
Not a very... Why does he, why does he get a better cage than me?
I should be a bigger threat.
I'm insulted that...
I'm insulted that they didn't give me a better cage.
I should be a bigger threat.
Why did they make it so easy?
They underestimated me!
...
Welcome to the Buddha's realm?
Why does the Buddha hate me?
...
Could it be all the murdering?
No, no, no, no, it can't be the murdering.
...
There's apparently an incense here.
This entire section was made for M's.
What do you mean by that, Buri?
No!
Oh no...
Is this a maze?
,
Oh no, is this why he doesn't want to leave?
...
Oh my god.
Go back to my cage.
...
Oh no...
Is this a maze?
IS THIS A MAZE?!
No...
NO!
I get it.
It's not a maze.
It's something much worse.
It's gravity.
It's actually gravity.
This place is actually the worst.
There's never one experience in again.
Sour, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't understand.
All the fucking maps before then.
They had invisible walls.
How could they just remove that?
How could they just suddenly remove the invisible walls?
That should be illegal.
I would like to talk to the prison warden's manager.
And so thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I would like to...
I would like...
Wait, what?
What happened?
Wait, what the fuck is that?
What the...
What's going on?
Wait, what are these?
I don't know what they are and I'm scared.
I don't...
I don't know what they are and I'm very scared.
Oh no.
Oh no, okay.
It's fine.
Poke!
Oh shit, a thousand and six?
That's a lot.
Oh fuck!
Okay,
now I understand what it does.
No, no, you do not get to put me down there.
Now I understand.
Now I understand what they do.
Oh no.
Okay.
We gotta get rid of him.
I understand now.
My HP is gone.
My maximum HP.
Oh god.
It drains my HP, yeah.
Oh no, please.
Please.
There's no way he attacks me, right?
Oh, I think he does.
No, where did he go?
Where did he go?
This is not fair.
Oh, oh, I see.
Oh!
He kicked me.
He sparred on me.
He actually sparred.
That's so fucked.
That is so fucked.
Man, I can't believe it.
He actually sparred on me.
Oh my god.
Now I know why everybody hates this level.
Oh.
Alright.
Okay, let's grab this.
Um...
What do I want?
After six successful hits with the first four moves during mobile spin, each talent barter increases maximum mana.
Oh, we like the mana.
I like the mana thing.
Alright, here we go again.
Here we fucking go again.
Oh!
Okay.
Alright, that's good.
They only live for like...
That's good.
Guys, guys, that's good.
They're only alive for like once.
If I killed them, they're dead forever.
That's good.
That's good to know.
Oh, where is the other guy?
Wait, where did the other guy go?
The other guy is gone.
Where did he go?
She lacks critical.
Please let me live in my ignorance.
Let me...
Let me live in my fairy tale.
I like...
I like living in my fairy tale, guys.
Wait, what's this?
Is this new?
No, it's 36.
It's definitely not new.
Alright.
I definitely am very poor right now.
Oh, what's in here?
Hello?
You bad guy.
I see you.
Thank you for the will.
Because I'm broke right now.
I'm so broke.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh!
It's fine.
We're better.
We don't need...
We don't need the extra... extra stamina.
We're so much better.
Wait, how do I get there?
Okay, clearly, like, I'll get out of this part.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Snake head mushroom.
Is there, like, extra will here?
I literally see you.
Okay.
I did see him, though.
Guys, I did see him.
I didn't dodge him, but I saw him.
Let's see.
I guess we go this way?
Oh, wait.
Where's the exit?
There was, like, the little...
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Because there's an item here.
Oh, shit.
Wait, how do I get up there, though?
Oh, please don't hit me.
Please.
Okay.
We gotta...
What?!
We gotta be very careful here.
We gotta...
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
Oh, I don't want to be near the edge.
I don't want to be near the edge!
It's fine.
As long as I'm not near the edge, it's fine.
Boom!
Okay.
Nice.
We got him.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, you fuckers.
No, you fuckers!
Why?!
Bimby, get close to you!
This is not fair!
He's angry!
He has a grab?!
He has a fucking grab!
And he's back!
I missed!
I'm not okay!
He has a fucking grab.
Are you serious, where did he go?
Where did he go?
Oh shit, okay.
He's kicking me.
Oh, 1,600.
There's another one.
There's another one?
Where are they?
What do you mean there's another one?
Where is he?
Okay, there's not another.
Okay, I need a rest.
I think I realize why everybody... I think I realize why everybody hates this level.
I hate that.
I know now.
You know what?
I don't even... You know what?
I'm just gonna run.
I don't even want to farm this area.
I don't even want to be here anymore.
I'm willing to just run past everything.
I think I'm just gonna run.
I don't need the loot, guys.
I don't need the loot.
No, no, no.
It's fine.
We don't need the loot, guys.
The loot is not that good.
What do you mean there's even a worse part?
Why?
How can they make this section worse?
I don't understand.
I feel like I'm already experiencing pure fuckery right now.
There's no way they can make this a worse experience than what I...
There's no way.
What the fuck?
How?
Oh, God.
Let me grab this and then freeze him.
I can't.
I can't right now.
I don't care if I'm using magic.
I can't.
This area sucks.
Hey, I don't need the loot, guys.
I really do not need the loot.
I just want to be out of here.
Hey.
I need to be out of here.
All right.
Off we go.
Now I know why that guy was like...
He was like, stay in your cage.
Now I know.
He was right.
Okay, but, like, what if, like...
Okay, I know, like, I don't want the loot, but, like, I saw a chest.
And, like, I can't... I can't...
Chess equals shiny.
But, like, what about the chest, though?
I can't resist.
I see a good-ass chest.
Okay.
Open.
Oh?
What is that?
Are you...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Please.
I just wanted to open the chest.
Are you... Are you fucking...
Where?
Where is he?
Oh my god, there he is.
There's that fucker.
There's no way he sees me.
Just run?
Okay, I'm just gonna run.
I'm just gonna run.
It's not even worth it anymore.
I'm just gonna fucking run.
It's not even worth it.
I'm just gonna run.
I'm gonna get rid of these guys though.
Oh no.
Where do I run to though?
Is it over?
Did I just chill here?
He doesn't know.
Do not go outside.
Do not go.
Do not open zombie inside.
It's never open.
Keep running!
Oh.
Oh, it stopped.
I forgot there was fall damage.
After all of that, I forgot fall damage existed.
I didn't know.
I didn't fucking know.
I lived my whole life with no fall damage.
Oh my god, I just wanted to know what's down here.
I saw shiny!
I saw a shiny!
Next scene, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
I was like, oh, now I can finally open this box!
Nice, I got my fine china.
Woo!
Fine china, let's go!
Alright, we're leaving.
I do not care enough for this.
Alright, here we go.
I just saw shiny.
It knows my weakness.
It knows.
It knows that I can't resist the shiny.
It fucking knows.
You're so fucking evil.
Let's get to the very top.
It'll stop the health drain.
Oh, I like the sound of that.
Oh, but also shiny.
Shiny.
Alright, nice.
Alright, back at it again.
Am I at the top yet?
Woah!
Is it dead end?
Oh, this is a dead end.
God fucking damn it.
How the fuck?
This is a dead end, guys.
This is a dead end.
I'm leaving.
I don't care.
We're gonna figure out how to get out of here.
Oh, shiny.
Okay, but shiny though.
I know I said I wasn't gonna grab any loot.
But like, I can't help it.
When I see shiny, I must grab.
Oh, woah, woah.
That's not shiny.
Goodbye, guys.
Just gotta keep running.
No!
No, no, no.
They're back.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Get out of here!
Leave me alone.
Leave me alone, bats!
It's okay.
They won't know I'm here.
They won't know.
I'm so safe.
They can't kick me out.
I'm gonna wait here.
They won't know.
This is my safe spot.
This is my safe zone.
Please don't kick me out.
Please.
I'm not a squatter.
I swear.
I pay rent.
I pay rent here.
I live in New York City rent.
It's pretty spacious for New York City.
Not gonna lie.
No, they don't know.
It's all right.
My studio apartment.
Please.
Oh, God.
Where is he?
Where is the scary man?
I'm so scared.
$4,000 a month?
Wow.
That's a steal.
Just run.
I swear to God, if I get kicked off the cliff.
If I get kicked off the cliff from the guy that was like, just run.
I swear to fucking God.
Alright, nice.
Lamp man gone.
Oh no.
If anybody is gonna fucking die here.
Okay, that was actually scary.
I almost thought it was over.
I don't need that willpower.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
So far so good.
Oh.
It's alright.
I have 200,000 people chase me but it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh my god, are they still chasing me?
One guy is.
That one guy.
Am I safe now?
Am I...
Am I safe?
Oh.
Hey, who is he?
Who the fuck is this guy?
This guy is big boy.
Not big enough!
Shit!
Okay.
That's cheating.
You got a third party.
That's actually cheating, man.
I used magic but at least I didn't bring a buddy.
What are you?
With sword in hand, the foe's chest pierced.
Oh, he's red-haired.
Hey, at least the guy...
The journal didn't call him ugly this time.
And this guy was tanky as hell.
I had to use my mana on him.
Nope.
Leaving.
Not gonna deal with that.
Oh, thank god.
Is it over?
Is it...
Is it over, guys?
Am I free?
Am I...
It's never over.
What do you mean halfway?
What do you mean?
No!
Get me out of here.
Please.
I...
We are back to the boss the moment we fucking get rid of the team.
No.
Wait yes or no.
No!
Where's the boss?
Where the fuck is the boss?
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, it's- oh he's still there.
It's fine.
I can outrun him, right?
It's so fine.
We're so fine.
We're so healthy.
We're so... I feel so healthy.
It's fine.
We're gonna run.
We're not gonna let them bait us into the bats again.
We're not letting the bats win.
Stay inside.
Oh god.
Up we go!
I know he lives up there!
Oh god.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
The moment we kill the...
God damn stupid... I went the wrong way.
I went the fucking... Oh no!
There's There's so many people!
Shit.
I got stuck.
It's fine.
I feel so healthy.
Oh my god, this is it!
Oh god.
Oh god, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
Stupid fucking archer, but we're almost there.
It's fine.
I will freeze your ass to get you out of this lobby.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, please tell me there's gonna be an incense up top.
Oh, thank fucking god.
Thank fucking god.
Holy shit.
Alright.
He has to push up.
Fuck!
Alright.
There's an incense right here.
There's hope.
There's hope up here.
Oh, there's so much hope.
There's so much hope in the world.
Kyle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the pause at the very top.
Yes, I ran through everything.
This hell!
I don't need the loot down there.
I'll fucking...
I'll go back down when he's dead.
I'll go back downstairs when he's dead.
There's no point to be up there.
Alright.
Alright, there should be no more...
no more of those guys, right?
I'll go back!
I can walk back, guys.
It's not like I turn around...
I turn the car around.
I can turn back.
It's not that typical.
Oh.
Oh, Birdman.
Oh, hey, it's him!
Oh, hey!
He's a famous...
He's famous!
Oh my god, you're so famous!
Can I get your autograph?
I'm frozen.
You fucker.
Yes!
He has a thing!
That's right.
Big baby.
We'll get to the secret boss the moment this is all over.
Alright.
The falcon fan maker.
The swan soars high.
It's published lush.
Oh, hey, it's that guy.
Yeah, he controls...
He does the wind shit.
Okay, I don't like that I'm frozen.
That is... does not...
That does not bring me joy.
Wait, is that it?
What does he...
What?
What does he offer?
That's it?
What is this guy?
What was that for?
Yeah, yeah, I know.
But like, what was that guy for?
Monkey no light cold.
Monkey needs the...
The hot sauna water.
Yeah, yeah, but like...
Wait, was there a stutter?
Was there a stutter, guys?
I didn't notice a stutter on my end.
It was a bit...
All right.
I didn't notice any stutters on my end, though.
There's been a couple.
I wonder if it's the YouTube side.
Because like, I haven't been experiencing any stutters.
Is this him?
Is this the...
Is this the guy that's causing me so much pain and grief?
Captain wise voice.
Oh, look at...
At least he has toes.
Oh, he has multiple toes.
All right.
I swear to God.
Did I...
Okay.
I'm not having a...
I don't know if you noticed, but like, I'm not doing so hot right now.
Wait!
That's like...
What the fuck?
That's my damage?
What?
How the...
Where is my damage?
What is your weak spot?
Is it not...
Is the toes not your weak spot?
Where...
Are you weak?
No way.
Where are...
Where are you weak?
I don't understand.
What's the head?
It's the fucking head.
I will fucking beat your head up.
That's fucking right.
I don't even need stamina to do this.
Ugh, oh, it's gonna curdle.
That's fucking right.
Boom!
Alright.
It's fine.
Just keep hitting the toes!
The toes is weak point!
That's fucking right!
I found your weak spot!
Okay.
Nice.
That's fucking right.
I know where your weak spot is.
I know what it is!
You can't hide the toes from me!
Poke!
Okay.
Nice.
I gotta regen now.
Where am I?
Wait!
Oh!
That's where I am!
What the fuck?!
How?!
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
I stopped it.
I stopped the evil.
Okay.
I don't... I can't see anything.
I can't see anything sometimes!
Poke!
Oh shit!
Okay.
He does not like the poke.
Oh!
What the fuck?!
Okay.
Alright.
What is he doing?
I can't tell!
What is he doing?!
What?!
Oh my god.
How?
Actually how?
Holy shit!
Oh!
I had to jump!
That's actual bullshit!
Let me... get me at your toes!
Okay.
Bye-bye.
This is fucked.
This is actually fucked.
Bye.
Please.
Oh please!
This boss is bullshit!
Toes!
Oh my god.
This...
This boss is actually bullshit.
My ch... My wolf barely does anything!
Baby!
Come on!
Give me the baby!
Oh
god.
Oh god.
It gave me the baby.
Oh thank god.
Yes!
First try!
Oh thank god!
I didn't want to finish!
I don't want to fight him again!
Oh!
That's right!
Get out!
Get your bullshit freeze out of here!
I'm disappointed.
You should have done better.
You should have tried him again!
How dare you be good at this game!
I demand another shot!
Oh my god.
Thank fucking god!
Wait!
It's gold!
Is this stronger than Big Baby?
How dare you not suffer!
Wait!
It's gold!
Let me start the game right now!
The captain lies.
Alright.
Oh I don't even get to use it?
But I absorbed him!
What do you mean?
Alright.
Time to fight.
We're running it back now.
Now we can run it back.
Now!
We can actually...
Oh shit.
I almost fell off just cause.
Oh.
Oh thank god.
I don't know if I can craft new armor now.
Cause I was broke before.
Oh I can!
Thank god.
Alright.
Let's grab that.
Confirm.
And then... Oh!
29?
Wait.
What?
Why the fuck did I make this one?
Okay.
Alright.
Let me make this one too.
Let me...
Alright.
Now we make this one.
Confirm.
Alright.
Cause I don't read.
That's a good answer.
Good answer.
Alright.
Let's see.
We can finally head back downstairs.
See that one guy that was like, no you need a...
I wasn't even able to beat the boss because I had to collect all the stuff while I went up there.
That's right.
I told you guys.
I'm a fucking gamer.
Let's go.
Alright.
Nice.
I don't need no magic.
Okay.
Maybe I should.
Give me a sec guys.
I need to get my magic.
I need it.
I realized I have no magic.
And like... I don't know.
Wait.
What the fuck?
I might... I could possibly die.
That's right Tommy.
I didn't need that loot Tommy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
We can head over.
Let me use the bathroom.
Now I'm mentally ready.
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Now...
Now I'm...
I'm mentally ready.
When he... When that guy kicked me off the ledge.
I realized...
That was the day I realized I was not ready.
But now I am.
Alright.
Let's go downstairs.
Where is it?
Where even am I?
Like...
Is this where I'm at?
Alright.
We have to go to the...
Oh!
If I give this guy...
Who do I...
If I give this guy that killed the warden...
Does he...
Is he free?
Yeah.
But like...
I want to show him that I killed him.
I want to show that to him.
And be like...
Look!
I did it!
The NPC...
Yeah!
He's going to be so impressed.
I'll be like...
Yeah.
They should have given me a better cage.
Look!
I did it!
Okay.
He doesn't care.
I'm...
Alright.
He doesn't fucking care.
Okay.
I might as well just jump off.
Let me jump off!
Oh!
I have to get hit by them?
Alright.
Do it!
Kick me off!
Right now!
Do it!
Fucking do it!
Oh my god!
He can't even do it.
It's so fucking pathetic.
Wait.
There's the other boss?
I don't even know where the other boss...
Oh!
Hey!
There's loot.
Okay.
Just kick me.
Yeah.
But I'm lazy.
I don't want to deal with it.
Yeah.
I know.
But I'm lazy.
He could...
Kicking me off would make me...
If he kicked me off, it would hit me faster.
Okay.
Second shrine.
Jump down behind.
Okay.
This is a shitty prison.
Because I could literally just leave.
If I think about it.
I could literally just travel to the next area.
Jump down here?
Here?
I'm not gonna jump there.
You liars.
Oh, inside.
Okay.
Here?
No, you idiot.
This way?
Oh, the hole!
The hole is the goal.
Alright.
Here.
I fucking... Okay.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
What is he?
Wait, that's not fair.
How does he do that?
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Oh, that's legal.
Wait, that's fucking legal.
That's not fair.
It's not fair.
Ow!
That's not fair.
What the fuck!
Oh my!
Okay, this is actually really good.
Don't worry, I got you.
That's fucking right.
Even if it was in the... Oh shit!
Okay.
You know what?
That's right.
I don't think it does anything, but that's right.
That didn't do much, but that's fucking right.
Woo!
Oh, alright, nevermind.
Oh!
Okay!
Oh, alright!
That's fine!
Ah, alright.
Okay.
I... I don't know.
You please come down.
Please sir, get down!
Where am I?
What?
It's alright, I just hit him one time.
That's an accomplishment.
Oh shit!
You don't... Fuck this!
Magic hair!
Ah!
No!
Not the magic hair!
My magic hair!
This boss is so fucking... What?
How is this boss harder?
There's too many things...
I don't understand.
How are you so difficult?
Okay.
Smack that!
Please!
Please let me smack that!
No!
This boss is so fun!
Oh my god, he's actually more difficult!
How?!
Where's my gun when I need it?!
I have to fight this fucker!
The fuck do I...
Jesus Christ, I hate him.
I've never hated.
I've...
I've never hated him!
He has a gun!
That's not fair!
He literally has a laser gun!
I have a fucking stick!
Alright.
I get it, I'll go.
This is so not fair.
This is not fair.
And I take damage getting down from here!
Like...
Oh my god.
I should not be taking damage getting down from there.
Fuck this magic hair.
I...
It won't let me use magic hair!
This fucker.
This fucker!
The boss gets...
You can land on the roof?!
Well, that's good to know.
Now that I know you can land on the fucking roof.
This is not fair!
He's literally made of rock!
I mean, I'm literally made of rock too.
But like...
But like, I have less rock percentage than him.
Like, he's like 99% rock.
Oh my god.
I think the hardest part is the fact that like...
I...
If I like...
If I get hit by one of them, I get hit by all of them.
Like, I...
Oh my god.
You're not Wukong.
You're just hair.
You're not him.
Alright.
Okay, here we go.
I land on the roof this time.
Oh my god.
I did it.
I...
Okay, it doesn't...
Okay.
Alright.
I did...
I did not mean to do this.
I...
I care.
This is it.
I can't.
I actually cannot.
I...
We're all gonna fuck this guy up right now.
Alright, that's cool.
That's fucking cool.
I didn't mean to heal there too.
That's already...
Alright, transform!
Transform!
How much did I do?
How much damage did I do there?
Oh, it does not feel a lot.
It does not.
Let me go!
Oh my god, Pourquoi.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please free me.
I don't deserve this.
Okay.
Nice.
I actually used that thing.
You know, that thing.
Oh, never mind.
I almost used it.
Oh god.
Thank you.
I finally used different mechanics, guys.
Holy shit, guys.
I did it.
I used other mechanics in the video game.
It only took this one fucking bastard.
I never had to use it until now.
Oh god.
I don't know.
I don't know how I feel about this.
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
That's okay.
That's not okay.
Please.
Okay.
Oh god.
He's so far.
Please.
Please just one hit.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
I've never hated a boss more than this one.
This boss was so much more frustrating than...
Than the other guy.
Than the main boss.
He's actually so much more frustrating.
Holy shit.
What are you?
All things are bad.
There is no waxer, Wayne.
Like I'll never know what you are.
I've never hated a boss more than this one before.
Okay.
Where am I?
Where even am I anymore?
I can't tell.
No.
This guy was worse than...
Actually no.
Baby is worse.
Baby is... God damn it.
No.
Baby was definitely worse.
You're right.
Baby I was so too under level to even fight Baby.
Alright.
Get out!
Oh.
The locks are gone now?
I didn't even notice it.
I was too busy trying to kill these...
What the fuck?
Oh God.
I don't have any mana now.
I don't...
I used up all my mana for this.
I think I might need to transform.
I'm too lazy.
We have to transform.
I don't want to risk it.
Already went through so much.
Keep attacking Wolfman!
He's dead!
Keep doing your thing!
Oh God.
He's still not dead?
He's still not dead!
Oh shit!
Okay.
It's fine.
He's dead.
Now he's dead.
Oh.
Absorb.
Wait.
The...
The wolf has an ult?
Wait.
What do you mean?
I only saw two.
How do I use...
The wolf has an ult?
What?
Wait.
What do you mean?
You...
No.
You're lying.
That can't be right.
You...
You're lying.
You were lying.
You're lying?!
I hope he still believes it...
No.
You have to be lying to me.
If you build up the light, move, you get a third move....
Oh my God.
Who the fuck ever uses the light?
Other than now because I didn't want to waste it.
I can't believe the wolf has it all.
Alright, let's recharge this.
I can't believe it.
Every day I learn something new.
What the fuck?
Alright.
I just want to make sure I grab everything.
I don't know why I'm stuttering.
Is it the 1440p?
That's really annoying though.
I'm sorry guys.
I feel like every fucking stream I'm trying to...
Every stream I'm literally experimenting with new stream settings.
That's annoying though.
Maybe or YouTube.
So it's just YouTube?
Is there anyone that's not stuttering?
Oh, it's YouTube.
Okay.
I don't know.
That's the thing.
I don't know if it's my end or like YouTube's side.
That's like the hard part trying to figure it out.
It could be YouTube then.
Okay.
I mean, the easiest way to find out is like when the VOD's over and we rewatch it.
Guys, I don't know what I've explored and what I haven't explored.
Like, everything looks the same to me now.
Like, it's all blurring together.
Everything's literally blurring together for me.
I can't tell where I'm at and where I'm not at.
Actually, I don't need that will.
You can have that.
Now, YouTube's been like super weird lately though from what I've heard.
Alright.
At least the stream quality looks good.
Fuck.
Okay.
I was not paying attention to my stamina.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, can I free that man?
Alright, it's time to free that man.
But also, I want free... I want the loot here too.
Hello, I'm here for the loot.
I know it's your loot, but I'm here for it.
Maybe it's because my CPU is at... My CPU is though?
Oh shit!
Alright, give me a sec.
I'm gonna see what the ult is.
My CPU is at 100.
I'm not sure if that's causing stutters too.
Alright, come on.
Where's the ult?
How do I use the ult?
How do I use the ult, guys?
How do I use it?
Oh, here it is.
I figured it out.
And then...
Is that the ult?
Is that it?
Nice.
I don't know.
I don't know how to fix it.
I'm not even streaming under CPU too.
That's the thing.
I'm not streaming under...
I'm using the video for my streaming for OBS.
So, like, I don't know how to, like, lessen the CPU load.
Because, like, I have...
I think the issue also is that I have, like...
I also have, like, you know, all my, like, VTuber stuff on.
And everything.
Check it.
The game is using my graphics card.
Well, shouldn't it be using my graphics card?
Like...
No, I do not have 50 tabs open!
Get out!
I did it!
I killed him!
It's me!
Wait,
you're captains?
I knew it!
Sam!
You're not gonna say thank you?
Oh, you're blind?
That's me!
I'm the chosen one!
Alright,
so we have to kill yellow bro.
If I could, I'd end his suffering before he could even talk because he didn't even say thank you.
Alright, he's saying the same thing.
Alright.
We gotta find the... where the fuck was the first shrine?
Like, where...
Okay, no.
This is the one time I use my item because I can't be bothered now.
I'm just like...
This is too much.
Oh, I never even took one of these!
Okay.
Alright.
Let us take one.
I never even did this.
I...
Okay.
Alright.
I made the game a lot harder for myself.
Okay.
Journey to the first move of...
It's like...
Extends invincibility duration of the first move of all varied combos.
Wait, which one do I get?
Whistling wind?
Or...
Or all ears?
I don't use the rock so, like, it doesn't matter.
Which one?
Whistling wind?
Or all ears?
Three?
Alright, three.
Fluffy, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Recently, I had my birthday so I decided to give you part of my gift for always brightening my mood!
Thank you, doggie, for being there for me!
Thank you for the super chat, Fluffy!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy birth...
Oh, wait.
I was trying to use this.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Fluffy!
Yeah!
Instant transmission!
Let's go.
Alright.
I think I looted enough.
I can't be bothered to find more loot now.
I don't know where else to go.
I think I...
Fuck it.
I looted enough.
I don't know.
I've given up already trying to figure out where to go.
Can't...
I mean...
We...
That must be all of it, right?
Yeah.
It's just like one or two...
Two wills?
There were a lot of purple lock cages.
Yeah, I got...
I'm pretty sure I got all of them.
Yeah, totally.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Oh.
It's really pretty, though.
I like the boss...
The boss areas are like really pretty.
I like how they have like their own separate arena, too.
Yeah, I got the most important stuff.
Guys, if I get more important stuff, I'd just be too strong.
I'm trying to make it fair for the bosses.
I'd just be too strong and it'll be just too easy.
I think the game so far...
It's been really fun.
I've definitely been enjoying it a lot.
Alright.
This way.
Off I go.
What is this?
It's an open area, so...
Is there gonna be monsters?
I get this chest for free?
Nothing's ever for free.
What's the catch?
What's the fucking catch?
Huh.
Oh, wait.
I do get it for free.
I guess there is no catch.
Free loot.
That's so...
That's so weird.
I'm not used to free loot.
Oh?
Alright, this way.
Oh, there's Will, though.
Free Will, as well?
Is it...
Is it Wukong's birthday?
I wonder.
This is not fair!
Why can't I jump off the tree?
Yeah, but the...
Like...
It's...
Like, of course I didn't think there was fall damage!
It wouldn't let me do fall damage!
Like...
No...
Alright.
Nice.
Lack of mimics is often disappointing.
There is a lot of mimics.
I just don't bother grabbing the plants anymore because I don't use the items anyway.
I don't grab the items.
So I don't grab...
It's like it's these things...
I don't even...
I don't even grab...
Like, use it.
Alright.
Potions are OP.
I don't need potions.
Let me just grab this though.
I don't think I've used a single potion yet.
Oh shit.
Because I'm lazy.
That's way too many buttons.
That's like...
That's an extra button input that I don't want to do.
If I'm still killing them, does it really matter?
Does it really matter if I'm still killing the monsters?
Yeah, I'm hoarding all my potions for the final fight.
Chat.
Don't worry.
That final fight where I use all my potions, it'll be worth it.
Oh, nice.
Maximum mana.
I like that.
Yeah, I'm saving them for Wukong too.
Let's see.
Obviously.
Y'all get out of the snow first so it doesn't matter for me.
I have plenty of time to charge it up.
And then you have to grab your knife too.
That was worth it.
Cyber, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My birthday was yesterday but I couldn't catch yesterday's stream.
Could I get a birthday shoutout from my OSHA?
Of course, Cyber!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Cyber.
Look at these fools.
Just standing there.
So Pokeball!
Alright.
Is there anything up here?
Oh shit, what the fuck.
There's a lot of stuff over here.
There's a lot.
Alright, one by one.
Get all that willpower.
Alright.
I'll get you too.
That's fucking right.
You thought I could do anything?
That's right.
Oh shit.
Oh, I keep forgetting.
Hey, what's this?
You're protecting the tree pearl.
Yeah, yoink mine now.
Should protect it better.
Andrew, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So what you're saying is saving your suffering wasn't worth one extra button click?
Oh, no.
Doki, no.
Andrew, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm just a gamer.
Oh shit.
What's wrong with your head?
I think you gotta get that checked out, man.
Like, I don't think that's normal.
Bro, I think...
Bro, you need to get that checked out, bro.
Hey, don't worry.
I got you.
And your suffering.
I'll check it.
I'll pop it.
I'll pop the pimple.
Alright, what kind of yaoguai was that?
Oh, hey, seeds.
Huh.
I killed it before?
I killed giant pimple man?
I killed giant pimple man before.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Charging it up.
No, I wasn't talking about his bald head.
I was talking about the giant fucking tumor on the top of his head.
That was what I was focused on.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
There's that guy that the journal said he was ugly.
He was ugly too.
That's just his bald head.
It's not a tumor.
That's worse.
I was just telling you to get it checked out.
That wasn't that worse.
I was concerned about his health.
Poke the guy.
Alright, nice.
I'll hydrate real fast, too.
Oh, and there's extra will!
Yay!
Will time!
Alright.
Oh, this way.
Wait, but what's over here?
Nothing.
Okay, never mind.
This way!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Reparation funds from Malaysia due to our 50-0 loss yesterday.
Thanks for making me smile during the convention at home, Doki!
And yes, I bought the merch at the con!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm glad you were there to witness...
um...
public humiliation on the dragon.
Witness me!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Bro!
Wait, wait.
There's people going up the stairs, so I'm gonna go backwards.
Yes!
Now what's over here?
Is it a boss?
What's over here?
Wait, what?
Is this the right way, or is this the extra way?
Alright, nice.
Willpower.
Will!
Is this the right way, or is this the side way?
Is it an extra way?
I'm glad.
I'm glad you guys were entertained.
At first, I was like, should I grant a little bit of mercy?
And I was like, nah.
No mercy.
Alright, let's see.
Reduce the stamina, jump.
I don't know what to upgrade every time.
I'm just...
I'm literally just doing it as I go along.
Let's see.
I guess staff stances?
I'm using this a lot, so...
Maybe?
Alright.
First time!
Boom!
Oh.
He's like way far.
He's way too far.
First time!
Go stairs first?
It's a bit shorter?
Oh!
I thought this was extra!
I thought this was like the bonus area.
Alright, I'll go back.
I couldn't tell which was bonus and which was like part of the...
which is like the main storyline.
Alright, I'll go up.
Up we go.
Boop!
Alright, what's over here?
Oh, gather!
More materials that I'm never gonna use!
Oh no.
Oh no, I don't like this.
Guys, I don't like this.
Cause like...
There's a lot of pathways.
I might be lost.
Not another instance already?
Thrust.
Might be stuff over here.
Alright.
That's okay.
Cause I get a little bit closer...
Boop!
Oh shit, you lived.
That's not part of the plan.
You're not supposed to live.
Alright, whatever.
You know what?
I'm just gonna beat you up regular style.
That's right.
Congratulations!
You get the regular beat-em-up.
That's like extra will too.
What if I'm like...
If I'm missing any like...
loot.
Cause it's such an open area.
But like, there's nothing here.
Such an open area but like literally nothing.
Yay!
Oh, I got beads!
Nice.
Oh, I should have used those guys as landmarks.
I'm already...
Wait, what the...
What the fuck is that?
What?
Now nature hates me?
Lolis, why?
What did I do to nature?
Other than like burning a couple of plants, what did I do to nature?
Wait, this guy has a different pose.
Alright.
Nice.
I should have used these... I need to use these guys as landmarks cause I'm actually really confused.
Like...
I'm like...
I'm a little bit...
Like... I'm very...
Not even a little bit.
I'm very confused.
I'm actually very confused.
It's just all...
It's all snow.
Snow is like the sand of winter.
Oh, there's a chest.
Thank god.
Snowland.
Nice loot.
Alright.
Oh, where am I?
Which way was I heading towards?
Is it here?
Wait, he's not frozen.
That's illegal.
They said in the snow...
Oh shit!
Okay.
I was told that everybody in Snowland had to be frozen.
You're not a native at Snowland.
Oh fuck man.
I still don't know your patterns.
You die so fast that I never bothered learning your combos.
Alright.
Wait, you again?
That's fucking right.
We used a baby.
You're too strong to be left there.
Wait, do they respawn?
They don't, right?
They're like the eagles.
They don't respawn.
It's alright.
Nice.
Fuck.
Okay, you.
Get out.
Get out of my lobby.
Yay!
Absorb!
Okay, we gotta get rid of the Lotus.
You know, it's nice though because I feel like this is the longest I haven't had to fight a boss.
Which is pretty nice.
I forgot what that was like.
Just exploring.
This has been the longest since I get to actually not fight a boss.
Alright, goodbye.
There's your mimic.
You know what?
No.
Fuck it.
I forgot they were pretty tanky.
It's been so long since I fought a mimic.
I read that out of tanky they were.
Holy shit.
Alright.
Where am I?
You again?
You're still here?
Oh shit!
Okay.
That's fine.
We're gonna use the heavy attack.
Boom.
Okay, nevermind.
I don't feel as fine anymore.
I don't feel as fine.
Nevermind.
It's...
He's extra strong.
That's fucking right.
No.
I don't have enough mana now.
It's okay.
Wow!
What did you do?
What are you doing?
What are you doing, Wukong?
What are you doing, monkey?
There you go.
Easy.
I don't know why he paused there.
I have no idea why.
What the fuck?
Bro, I was fucking absorbing.
You don't just stop a man from absorbing!
That's rude!
Boop!
Alright.
You can't just stop a monkey, man!
When he is absorbing, you just can't stop!
He's monkeying around.
That's fucking rude!
Where am I?
Did I go in a circle?
No, this is new.
This is new.
Thank god.
Okay.
I was worried because I saw all the bridges.
Oh my god, please.
I was a little worried there because I was like, oh no.
Yeah, I brute-forced that one.
Oh, it's an item!
It's an item!
Tumor man!
Boop!
Big baby.
I need your loot!
I know this is your loot, but I need it!
Oh shit!
Don't worry, maybe I don't need it!
Maybe I don't need it!
I'm so sorry!
I am so sorry!
Haha, JK!
Wait, is it actually stuttering like crazy now?
Maybe I'll turn down the graphics.
Or is anybody...
Is it just...
Is it everybody?
Oh...
Alright.
It's getting worse.
Oh, it has to be YouTube?
Oh...
Oh, not my fault?
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Hahaha!
Oh, thank god.
I feel like it's always...
I never know.
I always think it's my fault.
Hahaha!
Oh, thank god.
Oh...
Hahaha!
Oh, not me.
Thank god.
I knew it's never my fault.
Hahaha!
I always have so many problems.
I assume it's always my fault.
Hahaha!
There's a horseman?
I'm fucking lost.
Alright, nice.
Wait, I think I actually hate this map more than the sand map.
Hahaha!
I think...
I think I actually...
I think I actually do hate this map more than the sand map.
I'm so fucking lost.
Hahaha!
I'm lost in the mountains.
Please somebody...
They're gonna make a documentary about me.
Hahaha!
And not the one where I survive.
Alright.
Nice.
What the fuck?
Wait, where... where does this go?
Or...
What?
Where am I?
What the fuck am I?
Hahaha!
Where am I?
Alright.
Wait.
Upgrade my stuff?
Do I have new upgrades?
No, I don't.
No, wait!
I finally have enough money!
Oh my god, I finally have enough money.
Okay.
Nice.
And I have a 6% critical chance now.
Now I have the ice spear.
Okay.
I don't have new armor yet in a while.
Alright.
Hello.
Oh, is this like the werebear?
Hahaha!
He has the circle.
Oh, shit!
Wait, what?
Baby!
The weremonkey!
Oh, shit!
He has the wings!
Stop faking it!
Why don't I get the...
He has poison?!
Bro, pick one thing!
Why are you everything?
That's not fair!
Hahaha!
You can't give me a fucking bat!
A bat poison monkey!
Okay.
Powerups!
Oh, god.
Oh, I need a fucking heal.
I need it.
Thank god.
Fake monkey!
How dare you be a fake monkey!
Oh, god.
Alright.
Boom!
That's fucking right.
Whoa!
Don't worry.
Freeze!
And then you should be...
dead.
Oh, now you're dead.
He's a freak.
This is why...
This is why you're no longer accepted the monkey circle.
This is why.
Every other monkey picked one.
I was the magic monkey.
But you picked too many monkey!
Friend?
How are we friends?
The bat is right in front of you.
From Monkeyland.
Oh my god, I'm in the circle.
Now the... now the weird monkey can't come in.
Oh, it was Destiny?
Oh, am I gonna get fire power?
Oh my god, I got the power of fire!
And probably rapid recovery within it.
Wait, what spell is that though?
What spell is that?
Which one does it replace?
Okay, it could be cool, but like...
What spell does that replace though?
That's what I'm worried about.
Oh, it replaces freeze time?
Alright, nah.
Man.
I guess we'll never know how that works.
That's unfortunate.
We'll never know what it looks like, guys.
Feels bad.
Yeah, I think the stun is too good.
Guys, the stun is meta!
What the fuck am I gonna do with fire?
Alright, up I go.
I can't believe we'll never see the fire.
Other than the ones in the map.
Do be like that.
It heals.
Yeah, but like...
We're here to fight.
Wow.
I mean, the stun is fun!
The stun is also fun!
The stun makes me summon big baby!
Big baby is always fun.
It equals more fighting.
But stun equals die fast!
Big baby go burn!
No, I can't.
War.
Look at the number of tanks.
It's $3 ,000.
It's $1,000.
No, it's not.
It's like half a million oxen.
Or I wish it were a million oxen.
It's one lot.
But it's in a million.
If it's in a million, it would be a million, right?
Yeah.
Uh, I don't know.
Alright.
Then I'll start the fight.
I want a battle, not a fight.
I'm going to win this battle.
Wait, he knows where the relic is.
That's right, I did that.
Hey, I'm not that small.
I'm not that small.
All the other monkeys say that that is an average monkey height.
Oh.
Oh, is this those like...
Oh, is there those turtles?
Yeah, the turtles with the ladder on top.
Basement!
I'm sorry, I'll take a bath soon!
I know I should have taken a bath earlier when the first guy said I was stinky, but like...
There's so many fighting going on!
The new west.
Try my best, lady!
Oh my gosh, I have no...
I didn't even get a chance to rest.
Like, I went straight into the...
Oh, she grabbed me.
Oh my god, lady grabbed me.
I don't think I can one-shot this.
I didn't even have a chance to rest at all.
I just went straight into the fighting.
Holy shit.
Big baby!
That's fucking right.
And I didn't even need to freeze you.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Wait, he's back?!
It was you?!
Wait, there's no way you were the dragon?!
Oh, not you again.
Oh god, not her.
Not again.
Alright.
Big attack!
Oh.
If I stand in the center, I won't get hurt, right?!
That's usually what they say.
Whoa.
Whoa!
That's fine.
Oh, that's not fine anymore.
Never mind.
Oh, he doesn't know where I am.
Where could I be?
Please come down.
Please.
What are you...
What are you doing?!
What...
What am I doing?!
Oh, shit!
Oh, god.
Okay, I have no idea how to fight her.
Okay.
I'll just do, like, little slaps here and there.
Just...
Just one slap per hit.
Slap!
Okay, and then I run.
And I run...
No!
Okay.
And then, one, two, three, slap!
Oh!
Oh, my god.
I was supposed to jump.
Oh, no!
No!
Let me drink, please, ma'am!
And...
Oh!
Slap!
Never mind.
No, no, it's okay.
You don't need a slap.
Oh, please!
What has her moveset?
What the fuck is her moveset?
No, I...
Fuck this.
Oh!
Okay.
No, I'm joking.
I'm only joking, ma'am.
Ma'am, I was joking.
I was...
Just here.
Oh!
Heeeeeeeeee!
I'm sorry!
It was just heeeeeeeeee!
Oh my god.
What is that damage?
It was not fair!
I don't know what I was doing!
Guys, maybe I should have got the...
Maybe I should have got the thigh.
Alright, but what if I...
That's fucking right.
Alright, here we go.
We're all gonna slap her!
The multi-slap!
And the baby!
This is it, we're figuring it out!
There's so many of us slapping, she can't kill us!
Oh no.
Okay, now this is awkward.
Now what the fuck are my monkeys gonna do?
Like...
Nooooo!
My monkeys couldn't do anything!
Okay.
It's not fair!
Okay, that's fine.
I can stay here.
I'll stay in there.
Alt!
I did it!
Alt?
Hahahaha!
Did I do it?
Yeah...
Oh God, oh god.
It's okay.
I can tank all of this!
I'm just a little wolf guy!
She's wasting it!
Because that's not my real HP!
Oh no, wait, wait a minute!
Okay, but what if I...
STOP THEM!
Oh, okay, I can't stop it.
Hahahaha!
What if I just stop it?
Lil' did I know you can't stop it.
God, thank you.
Thank you for stopping.
No, I couldn't do the combo!
Nice.
Okay, bye.
No, no, stop!
Okay, nice.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I deserve that.
I actually deserve that.
Oh, no, please, please, please, please!
Let me heal now!
Oh, God, she let me heal.
She likes me.
She let me heal.
She likes me, right guys?
Poke!
Guys, I think she's like, playing hard to get.
Why else would she let me heal?
I don't know.
Oh, no!
Not again!
She loves us.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, please!
No, fuck!
Oh.
Oh, God, thank God.
Okay.
Oh, no, where is the... No, not the lion!
NOT THE LION!
Poke!
Do I get greedy?
I'm gonna get grea...
Oh, maiden down!
Maiden down!
Wait,
I let her live?
It's not fair!
I'm gonna let her live.
I let the others die?
Is this cause she's a maiden?
She's a dragon.
It's time to... We told them.
We had to make all dragons extinct.
Even if she's hot.
It's cause she's hot.
What the fuck am I gonna do with my... Oh, shit!
Oh!
Even though... ESPECIALLY the hot ones.
Eh?
Wait.
Isn't that...
Isn't that the pig weapon?
That's the ring.
Oh!
Thank you!
Wait, it's him!
Why is he so small?
Why is he so tiny?
What happened to you?
He's smaller than I remember.
She dead?
Why is he so tiny?
Did I say his name right in Cantonese?
I don't remember.
It's been so long.
I always remember Sun Wukong, but like...
He's a bad guy.
Oh my god.
The only names... I always remember his name.
I haven't said his name in a long time, so I was like, I don't know if I'm pronouncing it correctly.
But he's so tiny!
Why is he so tiny?
What happened to you?
Did you lose weight in that... in that area?
When you're trapped there?
Did you lose weight?
Oh shit.
I swear, if I die to a fucking... that.
I swear to god.
This version is so cute.
I could like, punch him.
Like a football.
That's how tiny he is.
He's like a cheap... yeah, he's like cheapy size.
Yeah, we could just give... we give him the piggyback ride.
Oh no, there's so much stuff.
What?
You're supposed to be frozen longer!
There's another dragon boss?
There's another one?
There's...
Oh my god, there's another...
Oh my god, where is the other one?
Oh my god, is he throwing a snowball?
Okay, what time is it at?
Okay, I just want to know like... hours-wise, how long I've been playing.
Alright, whoa.
Leave me alone!
Oh shit, we need to fly to the shrine.
Opposite end, okay.
I need to fly to the shrine.
I'm so far from that.
Where the fuck is the shrine?
Oh there it is.
I asked and I received.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, I can craft new armor!
Do I have enough money?
I do, thank god, okay.
Oh my god, 53!
That is a huge fucking jump!
From like 30... from like 30 to... 20 to 53.
Jesus, alright.
Nice.
Okay, and then...
Oh, 32.
Wait, that's good.
Yeah, I'll take that.
The trip improvement, yeah.
When will I get shoes?
Like, my feet... my feet is tired.
Like, my feet is like getting frostbite from all the snow.
There's another dragon.
Alright, where is it?
Where is he?
Where is the last dragon?
Oh, I see him.
Is that him?
I see him.
Oh, is he fishing?
What is he doing?
Hello, sir.
Are you fishing?
Hey, can I join you?
Are you Animal Crossing right now?
Time to ruin his day.
Did I kill your girlfriend?
Was that other dragon your girlfriend?
Were you trying to fi...
Well, she's dead now so you can stop fishing.
Oh, you were not fishing.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I don't think he was fishing, guys.
I don't think...
Wait, how come you're on two legs?
The other dragons aren't on two legs.
Bam!
That's right, big baby.
That's fucking right.
Backstab!
Boom!
And then...
It's fire time!
Boom!
He's just a big lizard.
Maybe he's not even a dragon.
It's like those, like, legless liz...
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Maybe I should stop talking right now.
Right now.
You know, like...
There's, like, legless lizards.
They're not snakes.
Because, like, lizards can blink their eyes but snakes can't.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
Oh, please.
I'm sorry.
Oh, he's...
Wait, what does this do?
What does that do?
What?
Oh, it's just...
He's just electricity now.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm not sorry.
That's fucking right.
Boom!
Oh.
Unlucky.
Oh!
What the fuck?
How does he have 200 million damage?
That should be legal.
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
Oh, God.
Oh, God!
Primates assemble!
I even have, like, 200...
They're all dead!
What?
That was all my magic?
That was actually all my magic, too?!
That's fucked!
That's so fucked!
Oh, my God.
That's all my magic!
That was all my magic!
I can't stop.
All right, now I know not to use the primates.
I know, I know that's useless.
Oh my god, they're useless.
Okay, come on.
Yes!
Oh, they got it.
I hit those.
Oh no, so cool.
He freezes the frame.
Oh no, I'm so scared.
I'm so scared.
Oh, this should be illegal.
Like that amount of damage should not be an illegal thing.
What?
Does he stun me?
Okay,
I learned, I learned the monkey.
Don't do the, don't do the monkeys.
Don't do the little, the monkeys, the primates.
The primates, they just fucking killed all of them instantly and that was a waste of my, that was my, a waste of my fucking magic.
Oh my god, he touched me and did so much damage.
It was so scary.
Hey baby!
Okay.
I stunned him a little bit though.
Oh, all right, that's fine.
Wolf time.
Oh god, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Please, please let me heal a little bit.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, nice.
Okay, if I hit him in the back he...
Aargh!
Never mind, I keep forgetting the tail.
Okay.
All right, nice.
Okay, don't hit him in the back because like the tail.
Okay, but like which side can I hit?
All right, eventually I'll figure out the right side.
What?
He broke it?
He literally, he broke my fucking stun.
That's fuck.
That's actually fucked.
That's actually so fucked.
You broke my stun.
Oh no.
Come on.
Nope.
Goodbye.
Stop the please.
The face is the perfect sheaf if I don't block with the face.
How do I block it?
Oh, god.
I need to leave.
Okay, nice.
Okay, that's... this is not the run.
I can already tell this is not the run.
Holy shit.
This guy is so hard.
Oh, my god.
This guy's actually so hard.
He hits so dark, too.
This is not fair.
I'm sorry for killing your girlfriend.
I'm not sorry.
I was never... That's right.
I'm never sorry.
And I'll do it again.
Okay.
It doesn't matter if I swap out the monkey spell.
It's still gonna take a lot of...
MP!
The monkey spell just takes so much magic in general.
So it doesn't matter.
I just can't use it.
Poke!
Okay, I'll leave.
Oh, okay.
Oh, fuck.
I forgot the second hit.
Okay.
Nice.
Stun!
I got the poke in, too.
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
What's he gonna do?
Swing his sword and I'm 200 miles away?
That's fucking right, you idiot.
That's right, you idiot.
I'm not there.
Oh, whoa.
Maybe I'm an idiot.
Okay.
I was a little bit silly there.
Okay, but what if...
Like... Boom!
That's fucking right.
Ah!
The tail!
Every time!
Why can't I do that with the tail?
Why is it dragon-specific?
Oh.
Freeze.
Oh, god.
Oh, he baited me.
He wanted me to freeze this fucker.
That's fucking right.
That's close to me.
Come on, you know you want to.
Come on.
I'm holding it.
Get a little bit closer.
Come on!
There we go.
I'm so sorry!
That was a joke.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry!
Oh god!
Why?
How did you predict that?
That's not fair!
I like that.
Come on, get close again.
You know you want to.
Come on!
JK!
Shouldn't have got close.
Okay, nice.
Oh shit!
Nice.
Oh, my stamina is gone.
Haha, that's fucking right.
Get close.
That's right.
You know you want to.
Come on, get close.
Come on!
Get over here!
That's fucking right, bitch!
Wait, can I cheese this?
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Wait a minute.
Am I cooking?
Am I cooking right now?
Wait a minute.
I was, in fact, not cooking.
I...
I think I figured out that I was, in fact, absolutely not cooking.
I... I might have...
I might have burned the kitchen.
I... I overcooked it.
Oh, my God.
Why is he so difficult?
Okay.
Maybe I don't waste this.
Maybe.
Big baby!
Oh, nice.
Okay, that's actually pretty good, actually.
No!
Okay.
Okay, maybe I might do light attacks.
And then... Oh, maybe not.
All right.
Big attacks.
Big attacks only.
Oh, no.
All right.
Okay.
What?
That hits me?
Oh, no.
That also hits me.
I'm sorry.
I keep trying to cook, but I...
I'm not a chef.
I know.
I keep trying to cook, but then I realize I shouldn't...
I should not be cooking.
Oh, run.
Run!
No!
All right.
He has to come down.
What comes down?
What goes up must come down.
Oh, fuck.
Not the tail.
Come on.
Wait, how did...
Wait, what?
It said I used the thing, but I didn't.
Guys, I don't think this is the run.
I don't think this is the run, guys.
I already used so much HP.
But, um...
Um...
Okay.
Nice.
No!
Oh, wait, I didn't get hit!
Boom!
Okay.
I didn't get hit!
Wait, I did!
I can't tell!
I can't tell anymore.
Did I get hit?
Did I not get hit?
Schrodinger's hit!
Oh, fuck.
That was not long enough.
Wait, what?
Okay.
I should...
I should have left.
Freeze!
Oh, my God.
No!
Okay.
No, we run!
We run!
Run!
We run again!
Boom!
Oh,
my God, I don't have any heals left, guys!
I don't have any heals left!
I'm so scared!
Please.
Please have mercy.
I'm just a little guy.
Oh, please have mercy.
I'm just a little...
Oh, shit!
Get out!
Oh, God!
Oh, God...
Oh.
Oh, please.
Get out of there.
Little guy.
No!
His little...
Oh, no.
We were so close!
I'm just a little guy!
No!
I'm just a little guy.
Oh my god, we were so close.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, full focus guys, I'm gonna full focus.
No more.
No more Mr. Nice Mukai.
No more Mr. Mr. How the fuck did I got damage from that?
Monkey strong.
Monkey see, monkey do.
Okay, now I gotta focus.
Hard focus time.
Come on.
Focus doki.
Poke.
Alright, nice.
Come on doki, keep focusing.
Back stab.
Okay, back out.
Back out.
We gotta back out.
Okay.
Freeze.
Back out.
Dodge!
Oh my god.
That was such a dodge!
Oh my god, not the fucking tail.
Ref!
Watch the replay that was a dodge!
Watch the replay!
Somebody watch the replay!
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, come Okay, dodged.
Okay.
Nice.
Dodge, dodge.
Smack!
Okay.
What?
That should not have hit me.
That was actually bullshit.
That was bullshit.
Oh god, please, Xenia, stop hitting.
Okay.
Oh, come on!
That was bullshit!
And you knew it!
You fucking knew it, you cheater!
Poke!
Oh no.
Last heal, last heal!
Okay, nice.
Back out, back out!
Oh thank god.
We got the baby in time.
Alright.
Wolf time!
Wolf!
Wolf power!
Go Wolf!
Oh!
Yes!
See your girlfriend in hell!
Bitch!
Ahhh!
I went full serious mode there.
I gamed.
I gamed hard!
Just for that one moment.
Oh my god.
The moment I said...
Alright, I'm going to go serious now.
It was over for that wolf man.
I mean that wolf dragon man.
It was so over for him.
The moma said it's wolf time.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You defeated our ceiling.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Alright.
I'm going to call it here.
That was a good fight to end it on.
Where's the fucking... where's the shrine?
I think that was a good fight to end this playthrough on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Not the super chat.
Thank you for the gift of ship.
Thank you.
Thank you Mike.
Wait, I can upgrade my wolf?
My wolf has not been upgraded in 50 years.
I...
Alright.
I have to figure out how to get back to the shrine first.
Oh my god.
My wolf... I don't think I've... I don't think I've...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
I was trying to use the talisman.
You... It doesn't stop them?
Instant transmission.
Alright.
Oh my god.
What a fight.
How do I upgrade wolf?
You can upgrade wolf?
That's possible?
Oh, I can craft weapons though.
Wait, what can I craft?
Wait, no I can't.
No, I was lied to.
No, I can't.
Oh my god.
What the fuck are these things that I need?
What a lie to me.
I said I could craft weapons.
I can't.
I don't even know what these are.
Okay I can brew though.
What did I get?
This?
What do I have?
Increases damage reduction?
No, we need damage reduction.
We 100% need damage reduction.
All right, set spells, cultivate sparks.
Okay, no baby can't be upgraded.
Wait, how do I upgrade wolf?
Oh, is this?
Oh yeah, that's the ring of fire.
And people were like, you need to use... hey, what the is that?
No, you can't.
He's just there.
You can't upgrade wolf.
I guess like transformation?
Is it this?
I have nothing upgraded by the way.
Wait, what do I get?
What should I upgrade, guys?
What transformation?
Also, Johnny Lacone Navi!
Thank you so much for the gifted chest!
Thank you, thank you!
Hey, what do I get?
There's moon, stead, duration or damage.
Okay, which one's duration?
Guys, which one's duration?
Is it... might?
Is it evergreen?
Or is it... which one is it?
I can't read this properly.
I see attack.
I see this one.
I'll get the attack.
Is this one?
Is the evergreen duration?
Might is duration, right?
Okay, we'll get that then.
All right.
I am reading!
I just don't understand!
I... I am reading!
That's a different thing!
Alright, we're gonna call it here.
That was fun!
I've been enjoying Wukong a lot.
I've heard that it's definitely a very long game though, so it's gonna take us like fucking forever to finish this game!
It's gonna take us so fucking long.
But it's been an enjoyable, wild ride so far.
And I'm gonna call it here.
It was not as long as my other Wukong streams, but this week has been a lot this week.
So I'm gonna take a rest.
I do have a convention later on.
A long day later tonight.
In like two hours.
Oh, in two hours by the way.
I have a panel in two hours, guys.
So I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
Thank you for all for watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed!
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!